madame monsieur bonjour les organisation
mondiale de la santé sont de plus en
plus alarmistes à propos de l'épidémie
de grippe aviaire dite grippe du poulet
qui ne cesse de s'étendre dans
l'ensemble du sud-est assiette plus de
20 millions de poulets sont déjà morts
ont été abattus la maladie croyais et on
ne pouvait se transmettre à l'homme
pourtant thaïlande ou au vietnam on
compterait déjà dit victime reste à
savoir maintenant comment cette maladie
peut se propager dans le monde en europe
en france sommes nous à l'abri
et bien ce matin paris a demandé
l'interdiction de toute importation
d'oiseaux en provenance d'asie sophie
rodier et christophe vallon bras à par
l'éleveur personne n'a le droit de
rentrer en france dans les élevages de
volailles les mesures d'hygiène sont
très strictes seuls les professionnels y
ont accès la paix stagiaire ou grippe du
poulet
ici on s'en méfie mais pas de panique
pour autant russes peuvent se
transmettre d'un pays à un autre
on a eu le cas pas s'il ya pas si
longtemps pour la peste aux pays bas
donc cessons des virus qui sont quand
même très virulent et qui peuvent se
transmettre
mais actuellement il ya aucune crainte
supplémentaire puisque là avec les
barrières sanitaires qui existe comment
ce virus pourrait-il arriver en france
tout d'abord par l'importation des
volailles mais par mesure de précaution
l'entrée des volailles dans l'union
européenne a été interdite
autre mode de transmission possible les
oiseaux migrateurs parfois porteurs du
virus tueur d élevage en europe sont des
élevages plutôt industriels et concentré
permet de protéger ces élevages du
contact avec les oiseaux migrateurs
beaucoup plus facilement qu en asie où
les élevages sont traditionnelles c'est
pour cela qu'on asie l'épidémie galope
déjà dix pays touchés par la maladie en
un mois et demi depuis hier la grippe
aviaire a officiellement gagné la chine
des millions de poulets et de canards
sont abattus et brûlés dans le pays
en indonésie malgré les recommandations
de l'om est ce le gouvernement n'a pas
interdit la vente de volailles venant
pourtant des élevages contaminés
son argument la maladie ne se transmet
pas à l'homme par la viande
je ne m'inquiète pas car je vend des
poulets frits et bouillie à plus de 90
degrés en thaïlande
six personnes seraient mortes au contact
de poulets infectés au total l'épidémie
a tué au moins dix personnes en asie
alors les pays voisins se protègent en
australie dans les aéroports les
passagers en provenance d'asie sont
contrôlés désormais plus question de
ramener la moindre nourriture d'un pays
visités